tonight's tiger starting pitcher is
spencer turnbull spencer's making his
second start of the season now the 2-2
swinging to miss perfect slider down and
away suarez strikes out one of the
tri-aces co-aces whatever you want to
call him one of the reds main man is
luis castillo how about that change up
swing and a miss strike three
just like that first strike out of the
night
the 1-2 pitch swing and a miss
four straight fastballs to jonathan
scope
and he carves him up with e mike
mustaches he leads off the cincinnati
second
got him looking
it's uh
it's just got the makings of one of
those knights two and two now to send
zell and a nice bounce-back effort by
spencer turnbull here in these 3-2
counts is to make sure the hitter sees
something that he thinks is going to be
a strike you want him to commit anyway
and he does
that's the best
gas he's thrown tonight jacoby jones
on the ground and that's a fair ball
inside the bag
romine will hit second chug for third
and he is
in there see jacoby
getting off speed pitch a change up
wonder if he was sitting on that we'll
have to ask him later on got to do some
damage here
good room
sends one to right should score him
castillanos in front of the wall he's
got it romine will tag so will jones
nico goodrum sacrifice fly puts the
tigers in front one nothing
spencer's got all three pitches working
tonight
look at that got him looking
second time that he's
sat down suarez with a k in the books
did he go they appeal
and yes he did cabrera rung up on
strikes he disagrees with the home plate
umpire castillo ahead of the ball in two
strikes
three straight changeups will take care
of castro four for luis castillo through
four and caspianos will lead off the
reds fifth
and that one will sneak through
and go into left center field on his way
to second base castellanos and he will
slide in head first with a double here's
senzel now that's a tying run out there
at second base
he left that up in the strike zone and
that's a base hit down the left field
line that'll tie the game
senzo on his way to second base a
game-tying double by senzelle
and now it's 1-1 as the reds have
knotted it up on doubles from
castellano-san nick senzel here's
barnard tucker struck out his first time
up
served into short left field it'll fall
in a base hit and how about tucker
barnhart
i just love this hitting right here and
and barnhart has done this he's gotten
to be a really tough out
98 mile per hour fastball joey to the
deck and in time to get the out at first
place good play by joey vado that's a
really good play and you see he's
applauding as you mentioned castillo
getting over there and reyes runs down
the line well that's that's good d
there's kristen stewart
goes the other way to left
that's deep that's going to be over the
head of the left fielder akiyama stewart
cruises in with a one-out double there's
austin romine walked and scored
detroit's lone run back in the third the
1-1 pounded down the left field line
that'll work stewart's going to score
easily romine's having himself a night
he'll trot into second with an rbi
double and the tigers bounce right back
here in the fifth to tie it at two well
there's another one sitting out there
pick them up jacoby payoff from castillo
back up the middle
beautiful piece of hitting they're going
to wave romine home senzel's throw is on
the way they let it come but it's not in
time
jones will go for second and get pegged
there but he delivers
the go ahead run 3-2 detroit
jones's 200th career hit paying
dividends two guys on in the inning roll
mine got to hit his last timeout romine
waits on the three two here it is goes
the other way and through the hole on
the right side what a piece of hitting
there reyes will score without a throw
and the tigers have bumped the lead to
two thanks to austin romine's solid
night
another good save by barbara here comes
demerit the toss made in time
got his hand in there with a head first
slide
krone drives one to deep left center
field senzel reaches out he won't get it
that's going to be a ground rule double
for cj krohn to lead off the tigers
eighth
first half bat of the year for travis
demerit
oh he jumped on it and sends it into the
left field corner
krone trots home so does reyes and
travis demerit has a two-run double here
in the eighth here's brian garcia to
work the ninth another one-two
pops it up there you go to left
reyes
has got it
and the tigers
at five and three just might be the
biggest surprise through the first eight
games of the 2020 major league season